moving to the east now where snow has
led to Major power outages and travel
trouble for hundreds of thousands of
people as this winter weather stretched
across a dozen states Lilia Luciano has
made her way to Fitchburg Massachusetts
for us in the snow Lilia good morning
good morning to you Tony I didn't just
make my way here I learned how to dig a
car from snow this morning as you can
see cars are covered this is what two
feet of snow looks like but it finally
happened after more than 24 hours it
stopped snowing here however the wind
and the cold are still an issue so the
roads are icy and all of that snow from
the trees is falling out on the roads
and putting some weight on the branches
so it's still dangerous and officials
are warning people to stay off the roads
if they can
Winter's first Nor'easter pummeled its
way across the region
dumping more than a foot of heavy wet
snow
honestly the heaviest
snow I've ever seen it should be a new
category she's just calling it snow is
not enough the power went out at
anatroch's home in Northern
Massachusetts she worried for her mom
who has health issues my mom's she's got
a heart monitor she also has a sleep
apnea machine that she needs to have
plugged in at all time thousands of
customers across the Northeast are still
without power including in Vermont where
Fallen trees line streets throughout the
state bringing down power lines even
forcing newfane's fire department to use
a generator it runs the whole station so
if we need to take people in and get
them warm or get them food or whatever
we can with that
and the storm also made traveling a
nightmare police in New Hampshire warn
drivers to stay off the roads to avoid
scenes like this one
and at least five semi-trucks jackknifed
at the Maine New Hampshire State Line
airports weren't spared either there are
more than 1100 travel delays and nearly
500 flights out of Boston New York and
Newark were canceled
well this was the worst storm of the
season so for new englanders like Anna
who are used to this much snow after an
unseasonably mild winter it's not too
much they know what to expect and how to
prepare for it and also there's the good
news that we're just a few days away
from the spring Tony
and the good news that you learned how
to dig out a car for your next move
you're gonna have to use the ice scraper
there on the windshield
thank you very much I did
nicely done